yeah welcome to the splits game against
mhb from from the u.s. at least and this
is what the flag is telling me playing
this line again Braunstein Larson oh no
is playing 95 this is yeah not
considered to be very very dangerous
like an even play 5 p.m. but okay can
also just develop pieces
yeah I cannot take d4 Knight f3 to e
fibers very embarrassing so just we
should be seven maybe don't think
there's some in a particular threat in
this position
yeah I don't want him to play Knight to
e5 yeah okay yeah this is this is just
giving up a piece for for nothing but
it's a blitz game so we will try to
muddy the waters okay simply it's simply
no compensation forth for the piece you
can I can take you six maybe maybe this
I can I can also go to you for I am
maybe go here maybe go here g-form I
play Bishop b4 25 I hear our evil
sacrifice even more stuff otherwise it
it's completely useless what he did
that's it's a blitz game what ok I take
I can take I can take each one I mean
it's not like he has got some some
deadly threat or something I can also i
can take the form so also know not much
wrong with that yeah let's take this
sooo
yeah I simply have done no I mean no
just sticks Tom are tons of pieces up
here Bishop Bishop each one is snare
threat I don't see anything I don't even
see a remote threaten considering that i
can return so much material already long
castles I take F form if I take F for
now he's got Bishop f seven and 96 okay
when I even this even this is not not
ridiculous because I'm so much material
up Queenie for though and I don't see
what he's doing after this more white
reason now it's just just too much
I i if i take here okay even even this
is I've got a look and what three pieces
for the Queen it's even this is probably
winning but okay Queenie for as much
much better I can also take the rook I
mean it's simply not working the
sacrifice so as simple as that you
cannot cannot play like that of course
not age 3 doesn't look good but okay
nagi 5 is a bad move for in the first
place so simply miss placing this piece
it's not the line with 97 this is
different ya can just develop the bishop
of course it's not like why does much
worse he can play Bishop d3 92 and
return it but you cannot play on a PC
profiles quickly am yeah okay thanks for
watching